so everybody whatever they're saying you
also have to take with a pinch of salt
because they're there Andrea Mitchell
I've been giving her a hard time because
she has been on the wrong side of this
for years and years and years and she
thinks I think basically she knows she's
a Jew and she's on TV and she kind of
thinks if she's anti-israel that maybe
she'll get beheaded a few days later and
that actually might be right uh but here
she is once again taking a Hamas line
and trying to spin it and Flor is not
having it that they have never had
incidents of their fuel being co-opted
they deliver it to people they know in
the hospital
these hospitals there were the the
amount of fuel that Israel finally
delivered to alifa was enough for a half
hour to an hour of what is needed to
generate their equipment so you have
babies dying taken off of incubators
first of all unra put up a tweet at some
point that their fuel had been stolen by
Kamas and then they had to take it down
because of course they're very much
intimidated these International
organizations and Kamas operatives are
very much embedded in these
organizations so everybody whatever
they're saying you also have to take
with the PIN Sal because they're there
and absolutely but remember that Gaza
even before October 7th had 4 hours of
electricity a day why because Hamas was
sucking all the energy out in order to
keep going this Terror infrastructure
that they had underneath so the priority
of Hamas has never been its people and
we're doing everything we can we're
sending incubators we've sent fuel we'll
continue to send fuel we cannot
guarantee that fuel is not going to be
stolen byas we were told by the
government that no no fuel is going in
we have images of fuel going in of
soldiers taking in fuel our soldiers um
are constantly in touch with the staff
of the hospital and we have even said
that it's not nearly enough but I let's
talk let's talk they're under
intimidation underneath them is a whole
Terror infrastructure iy I can't say the
word that I want to call her so I'm just
going to write it on my notes here just
write write it down a few times you'll
you'll email it to me I wrote it down
I'm going to send you this I'm going to
sign it and send send it you'll have a
Dave ruin official document um even at
the end there even at the end there give
they are giving fuel there is video
evidence of it but give fuel so their
babies don't die while they kill your
babies here here's the thing okay all
this information coming from the
government the Hamas government of Gaza
is giving you this information so let me
get this straight uh a regime that's
willing to go into Israel Slaughter 1400
people Mass rape women kidnap the
elderly behead babies they draw the line
at line to the
Press like that's where they're that's
that's what they won't do like we we
have to presume that everything they
tell the Press is honest and accurate
the B the body counts the the the things
that are happening with fuel yeah let's
believe them on that because they would
never ever lie to the Press after what
they did on October 7th I mean it's
insane and just yeah the basic premise
of it all is to put that at the feet of
Israel uh to put that at the
accountability and the responsibility of
Israel to even have to be responsible
for that when Israel was the one
attacked to Al Noah account she should
be sitting there saying you know laying
the full responsibility of this entire
campaign at Hamas that committed an act
of unprecedented aggression against
Israel so it's the worst crime since the
Holocaust against Israel and celebrated
it and that she's sitting down with
somebody and giving them guilt over the
suffering of the Palestinians that has
been brought on by this act of
aggression I mean like Meir said this is
not complicated and there are some
things so ridiculous only people in the
only an intellectual would say them
right I mean this idea of just this
moral confusion
and this this desperate need is sort of
masochistic like it's our fault it's our
fault we have you know there's this
there's this instinct to not want to
blame the actual people responsible for
this